well here is something you don't hear
many people in Hollywood talking about
waiting to have sex Devon Franklin was a
driving force behind heaven is for real
and Karate Kid and you have seen Megan
good in anchorman two and think like a
man - and they say they held out until
they were married to have sex and that
is the cues their relationship and they
told Michelle Turner why they had a
fairytale sunset wedding at a Malibu
winery almost four years ago he was a 10
million dollar movie producer turned
preacher who got his start in the biz as
an intern for Will Smith she was the
successful beautiful actress but their
love story which started when they
worked together on the set of jumping
the broom almost didn't happen I don't
want to be the guy that's known for like
trying to hit the hit on the talent and
also it's making good you think he's
cute though we never saw Thanksgiving it
was like you know he's the guy who gives
the job yeah you know I mean but but
he's cute now so much it right right
they dated 13 months before their I Do's
and their wedding night was the first
time they ever had sex you see even
though the two had relationships in the
past Megan has been romantically linked
to stars like Joseph gordon-levitt fitty
cent and Tyrese both Devon and Megan
became born-again virgins you know I've
been in several relationships since I
was 19 I would feel bad and I'd say well
let's try to be celibate and then I you
know of course be worried that they were
gonna cheat or worried that the
relationship was gonna end or whatever
it was and what happened is that the
relationship ended anyways I remember
Jessica Simpson talking about the fact
that she was saving herself for marriage
and then it went away now we're talking
to you all we're here Russell Wilson and
Ciara talked about this there's obvious
physical chemistry how tough was it to
wait oh it's us the hardest thing to do
in life you know it's interesting
because I I think I feel like it was
harder for me when a man finds a woman
he loves he will go through hell and
high water for her mm-hmm and even if
she presents this crazy idea about
waiting and he has no desire to wait the
wait that's the title of Megan and
Yvonne's new book filled with secrets to
finding the love of your life and the
life you love praying together you're
going to church together reading
together keeping God in our relationship
is critical and she's the number one
priority in my life number one and again
priority and marriage so the thing that
I love the same is it a man you want the
ultimate proof to wait works hello
you can drop the microphone right now it
is good